this is Startalk this is from kasi
rosemary who come to us for Instagram
hi Bill are there environmentally
sustainable printing material oh okay
let me go yes of course there are
there's recyclable plastic Mary name
person you never did you get her name
out did you ever manage them it says I
see your sassy
Cassie rosemary rosemary is the last
couple syllables yes Cassie it's very
reasonable that you'd have plastic that
is recyclable now I have from time to
time gotten hold of acorn plastic coffee
mug Quan plastic made from corn and it's
cool cellulose made from corn and they
don't last forever they they to
literally leak after a while but they
last a long time and they are meltdown a
bowl and they are made from organic
materials so it's very reasonable to me
is this as engineers and chemists and
chemical engineers keep messing with
this in the very near future we could
have completely recyclable plastic very
reasonable too many wheat sweet off its
sweet corn yeah look at that
stop it ah those were the ties now
here's the follow up is the makers
movement focused on going about the
manufacturing revolution in a matter
that takes into account the resources
that they are using well so much of the
make when you go to the Maker Faire so
many of the objects they are made from
recycled or repurposed materials so this
is something that is common is a
tradition yeah yeah and plus if you're
gonna if you're a person on a budget if
you're a normal person who doesn't want
to just trash money on a thing for Maker
Faire you find stuff to make things out
of hmm and that's good right what's not
to look right yeah but the whole promise
of the near future is to make anything
in any shape from recycled plastic or
recyclable materials yeah I mean that's
instead of just taking them come
pewter fan computer cooling fan and
making it into the drone flying drone
propeller right you actually grind up
the original fan and make it into the
perfectly shaped propeller gotcha and
you do it with renewable energy made
from wind and solar electricity so now
with that in mind do you you know when
the plastics revolution came about when
was it back in the 60s alright and
started throwing the Pluto platter
that's exactly to the frisbee and uh you
know we knew that this material this
space-age material was going to change
the world
no one took into effect the fact that
once we have it we have it okay it
doesn't degrade agree we made it and now
it's here now that we all in our oceans
and everywhere but when you buy a
plastic water bottle now it says on
there it's recyclable it says recycle
this I walk through the airport of the
subway here's the recycling right so now
with that in mind when we're
manufacturing with this wonderful
technology do we try to incorporate a
way that we can recycle for the
manufacturing on premise where where
where the manufacturing started or do we
stick to this just wait here that we
have now where we're dropping a
recycling that I'm saying that there'll
be a future with I know this follow the
following word is very troubling it's an
obscene word for certain people okay
regulations are you would not be allowed
to muck things out of anything
everything would be have to be made out
of environmentally benign material okay
I can easily see that okay you're not
allowed to manufacture stuff that
leeches bad stuff into the water supply
right monomers and cancer carcinogenic
pieces of molecules instead you
everything would have to be made
responsible you can easily imagine that
furthermore the free market would enable
it because manufacturers they check our
things out your dog can chew on this
without getting sick okay so now is
there
fringe no here's the thing that that's
your cat that's our core or your baby oh
it right where your chucks tonight your
wife hey hey did you like that cool
video huh well how about a bunch of cool
videos all commercial free plus
exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else all on Startalk
all-access calm